I have to ask this because I'm new to
the building I love working here it's
awesome yeah yes so do you love it do
you have like your favorite places I uh
it's fun seeing NBC like newscasters in
the lobby I've seen Lester Holt just
walking in jeans which is which trips
you out you're like you don't own
jeans we're born in a suit so Rachel
mattow I've seen of Starbucks um yeah
I know that Starbucks the subway
Starbucks right the subway Starbucks
have you ever been in there like really
early had a early call time it was like
6 something a.m. they were blast in
music I was like like it was like a
rave and you're like I looked at these
two and I was like it's 6:00 a.m. bro I
was like it's like that's ear was it
Kelly Clarkson music no not even great
I'm not going it's your music or nothing
your music or nothing it was actually
good people way life Time For a Moment
Like This I would have been more I
watched that and almost cried oh I did
cry well I was like Kelly deserves it
own
M Kell's a star thank you I was I
remember I was in college I was I was
just telling her the first season of
idol um our they have a person every
week too and ours was Bert backra came
on that week yeah and we did BT backra
songs I did Walk On By before DOA before
[Music]
[Applause]
thank you guys y have a great night I'm
going
home